the war in Ukraine is speeding up a
global departure from fossil fuel use
and the adoption of more Renewables
that's according to a new report by the
International Energy agency
the paris-based organization says Global
emissions are set to Peak by 2025 giving
way to cleaner sources including
Renewables Rising prices for oil gas and
coal are behind the trend the iea said
the war was leading to quote profound
and long-lasting changes in energy
markets
Claudia kenford is an energy Economist
with the German Institute for economic
research in Berlin she joins me for more
Claudia this report suggests a turning
point but it's not all good news to
limit climate change to one and a half
degrees by the end of the century there
would have to be a doubling of
investment in Renewables by 2030 to 4
trillion dollars is that feasible based
on what we know now
I think it will be feasible if the
financial markets are ready for it and
we need here the right Frameworks that
the money is suspended for for the right
direction into the Renewables and the
transition instead of fossil fuel
infrastructure unfortunately we see also
bad things going on on the global market
because a lot of investment is now spent
also in fossil fuel infrastructure or
drillings to fossil fuels which is not
in line what we need and hopefully this
will change
you touch on this government's doing
enough that question we also look at the
build out of Renewables itself not just
investments in fossil fuels if I look at
wind for example here in Germany there
are great aspirations for building out
wind at the same time that build out
actually drags along we don't see the
same kinds of approvals for example what
is the government going to have to do to
to push through a lot of these projects
yeah on the one hand indeed we need the
right Frameworks for it and the money
that they spend in order to increase the
share of Renewables in Germany for
example we need enough land which is
also provided to install the windmills
and also provide the right framework for
it and to reduce the barriers which are
still existing and I think that's true
also for the rest of the world of other
European countries to provide the right
Frameworks at the investment into
Renewables is coming instead of fossil
Investments we need a lot of Renewables
investment
the iea has also said in the past that
more countries should consider nuclear
as a clean energy option should that
also not be an option for Germany
new nuclear power plants are so costly
that it's not really an option look at
the new installations they need a decade
to be installed they need a lot of
Investments and we don't have the time
for it we need to be ready by 2030 and
Renewables are fast they are cheap and
we can install them all over the globe
and that's the answer to it nuclear
certainly is not we see that in France
how the problems occur if the power
plants are not maintained adequately and
the costs are too high so renewable is
the ends are not nuclear
this idea that we could see a peak in
emissions by 2025 could this take some
of the pressure off governments when it
comes to the kind of activism we've seen
when it comes to the kind of pressure uh
to speed up the process or does this or
is that urgency still there from what
you see
well I see an urgency coming also
because because of the war the fossil
energy War we are in and the Investments
are coming into Renewables and there is
a speed up process here which is good on
the other hand we also see investments
into the bad things that is fossil fuel
so I think the Ia is right by the peak
that they assume but what we really need
now is to have Investments ready for
Renewables and the governments which
provide the right firmware Frameworks
for it
all right cloudy comfort with the German
Institute for economic research in
Berlin thank you
thank you